rồi rà lô ở đi tìm đi nào.
Bây giờ các bạn đã bị sai chú dấu là só điều kiệt.
Rồi là trong bỏ trình gian giải quyết về tỏ nè,
thì khi mà kêm chi ở gài về cho cùng một cái rà chị.
Đi cái rà chị là anh đó này khác không.
Nếu không thì kè mình sẽ ra chờ cái lòng không,
thì sao người đi khác không.
Rồi các bạn có thể có một bỏ phương trình kì.
Kè giấu là họ kè mình có thể bây giờ.
Nhưng vậy là kè mình sẽ có trường chức em đừng vào năm 2020.
Nhưng tốt, dưới bà để grem có thể hậm chế được xa ngùa trồng đi.
Nè, kè mình cùa ăn tạo ra kè áp lực phòng thi.
Điều như trường tổ chức đi được hậm có thể được kẹn đi thi được.
Để có thể ngùa như trong ngon thi để ăn được phòng thi, gà mình thằng xa.
Đồng là người rất cua hay tụi.